mode the third largest democracy
freedom solidarity europe is very
important it's like i saw the
news and i saw
the wall fell and that the
border was open and i was happy
and yes i just cried at the
boarding school of a mario communist in the
block litter  in it we put our
typical lasts that is the longest
period and more direct television
[music]
international
[applause]
what soldiers or pakistan conclusion
planned book the more after what is
international
[music]
the judge rejected that
that started with some  few
who went to church on mondays for
monday prayers and the
number has increased and it wasn't
just people from leipzig
that in saxony they were from
brandenburg they were all from
berlin and they weren't alone either
the poles were the czechs  who were
around who helped the
austrians who the gre  nze have also
opened there are there have been
many who have accompanied the
[music]
of democracy
if we don't think back to it then
I think it's something incredibly
outrageous that today
people who are right-wing nationalists stand up and
say we're going to make the peaceful
revolution  2.0 and we are the people
that's such a mockery of the
people who took to the streets back then
that I really ca
n't believe this European barrick what we
created together
the end of an entire continent can really live
together after being artificially separated for over 40
years  it's been
that it's a european peace park and
that's worth developing further
[music]
grafik politik.de telephony
freedom has always been a very important topic for me
it's still today
and for me that was the point where i said
yes it's freedom  freedom is now
[music]